blake shelton hilariously blames his
taste in music on girlfriend Gwen
Stefani while contestant Jack Cassidy is
sent packing during Monday night's
episode of The Voice
[Music]
during the last knockout round of the
competition show David Cassidy's nephew
performed an emotional rendition of X
ambassadors hits unsteady but was no
match for the soulful Vanessa Ferguson
[Applause]
[Music]
Alicia sent her through to the live
shows which start next week Jackie these
are very sounds and guy but vanessa has
such an incredible style about her Jack
took it in stride getting emotional as
he said his goodbyes Alicia I'm so
honored and humbled to have worked with
you you're amazing later in the show
Brandon royal from Team Gwen performed
Bob Marley's Redemption song and when
country crooner Blake admitted to not
knowing the tune Alicia was not
impressed when you gave him listen to
the greatest says about Marley you
should know you know that's my
girlfriend
good luck that's her responsibility and
she hasn't followed through come on
[Music]